>> GREG: IT'S FRIDAY AND OUR
LAST SHOW IN NASHVILLE.
THEN BACK TO NEW YORK CITY.
I WISH I COULD EXPRESS HOW I
FEEL ABOUT THAT.
PLEASE DON'T LET THEM TAKE ME.
CAN I JUST STAY A LITTLE LONGER?
I WILL SLEEP ON YOUR COUCH.
I WON'T TAKE UP A LOT OF ROOM.
I SOUND LIKE CAT ARGUING WITH
HER HUSBAND. BUT TONIGHT, WE'RE
GOING OUT WITH A BANG.
LOOK WHO'S HERE TONIGHT?
OH, YES, IT'S MISS DANA PERINO.
SO GLAD, REALLY HAPPY SHE MADE
IT HERE.
HERE SHE IS ARRIVING IN
NASHVILLE. BOTH OF US HERE, I
WONDER WHAT "THE FIVE" WAS LIKE
TODAY?
THEY'RE ALREADY IN BED.
YEAH, HEP DOES.
PERINO WAS THE ONLY PERSON
SMALLER THAN GUTFELD.
YOU CAN SEE CAT'S HERE.
SO HOORAY FOR THAT. GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
MADE TO THE STUDIO GIVEN LAST
NIGHT'S ANTICS.
SHE MAY BE CLUMSY BUT HER
OPINIONS ARE AS CLEAR AS THE
TERROR IN HER HUSBAND'S EYES.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE MONOLOGUE,
IT'S TIME FOR --
>> GREG'S SEVEN JOKES.
NUMBER ONE, SHOCKING NEWS FROM
THE SET OF "THE VIEW" HOST ANNA
NAVARRO AND SUNNY HOSTIN TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
WORSE, "THE VIEW" TESTED
POSITIVE FOR JOY BEHAR.
IT'S INCURABLE.
THEY HAD TO RUSH KAMALA HARRIS
FAR FROM THE STUDIO.
IT WAS EASY.
THEY JUST TOLD HER IT WAS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GREG: DOG THE BOUNTY HUNTER
HAS JOINED THE SEARCH FOR
FUGITIVE BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
POLICE BELIEVE HIS HELP IS
CRUCIAL AS THEY BELIEVE LAUNDRIE
MIGHT BE HIDING INSIDE OF A
MULLET.
GOOD NEWS, McDONALD'S McRIB IS
McBACK.
THE BAD NEWS IS, SO IS MY
McDIARRHEA. ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH, SCIENTISTS SAY THREE
MASKS PROTECT YOU THE MOST.
WELL, I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR THE
RESULTS OF THEIR CONDOMS STUDY.
SAME PRINCIPLE.
AMAZON UNVEILED A NEW AMAZON
ROBOT FOR $999.
IF I'M PAYING $1,000 FOR A ROBOT
MAID, I BETTER BE ABLE TO HAVE
SEX WITH IT.
THEY'LL CALL IT THE
SCHWARZENEGGER. AND NO. UP, U.S.
AIRLINES ARE NOW CONSIDERING
WEIGHT LIMITS FOR PASSENGERS.
AND OTHER NEWS, BRIAN STELTER, I
HOPE YOU LIKE TRAINS. AND THAT'S
GREG'S SEVEN JOKES.
BACK TO THE SCREENING HELL
ESCAPE CALLED MANHATTAN.
DID YOU HEAR?
AS KIDS GET SHOT, JUNKIES TAKE
OVER AND ELDERLY GET MUGGED BY
GANGS OF THUGS, ALSO KNOWN AS
DEMOCRATS. THE MAYOR HAS
REDEFINED POLICING AS CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
>> LITERALLY THE QUESTION FROM
NYPD TO THE PEOPLE WE SERVE, HOW
DID WE DO?
FUNDAMENTAL CUSTOMER SERVICE
IDEA.
IT'S NEVER EXISTED PREVIOUSLY IN
THE NYPD.
BUT IT WILL BE THE FUTURE OF THE
NYPD.
THE VERY FACT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CUSTOMER SERVICE IN THE
CONTEXT OF NYPD.
THAT'S REVOLUTIONARY.
>> GREG: IT IS.
I'M STILL WONDERING HOW DID A
FESTERING LINCOLN LOG BECOME
MAYOR?
WHAT IS IT WITH DEMOCRAT
LEADERS? ONCE THEY WIN?
DO THEY TAKE A SECRET OATH TO
DESTROY EVERYTHING?
YOU COULDN'T RUIN A BIG CITY
FASTER IF YOU WERE MOTHERA.
DIBLASIO HAS TURNED A ONCE GREAT
CITY INTO A CESSPOOL OF CHAOS
WHICH IS LIKE GERALDO'S HOT TUB.
AND LIKE GERALDO'S HOT TUB, NYC
IS FILLED WITH HALF NAKED CRAZY
PEOPLE AND IT'S PRONE TO
FLOODING.
SO THE POLICE IS NOW CUSTOMER
SERVICE, THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S NO LONGER TO PROTECT AND
SERVE, IT'S LET ME HELP YOU
RETURN THAT DEFECTIVE GARDEN
HOSE TO HOME DEPOT.
AFTER YOU GET MUGGED, YOU CAN
STAY ON THE LINE AND UPDATE YOUR
CAR WARRANTY.
THE MUGGER IS RELEASED ON TO THE
NEXT VICTIM WHILE YOU'RE ON HOLD
LISTENING TO AIR SUPPLY.
AS CRIME EXPLODES, THE MAYOR
WANTS COMMUNITY GUIDES,
COMMUNITY GUIDES TO GREET
VISITORS AT CITY POLICE STATIONS
BECAUSE THEY HEARD THAT THE
POLICE WERE GRUFF AND
DISMISSIVE.
WELL, MAYOR, SO ARE THE MUGGERS
AND THE RAPISTS.
YOU JUST DESCRIBED EVERYBODY WHO
LIVED IN NEW YORK.
THE ONLY NEW YORKERS WHO AREN'T
GRUFF ARE DEAD. THANK YOU,
ANDREW CUOMO. GRUFFNESS THAT'S
THE PROBLEM HERE?
NOT MURDER OR ASSAULT.
NOW WE TURNED COPS INTO WALMART
GREETERS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH CITIES
RUN BY LEFTISTS.
THEY CONFLATE LAW AND ORDER WITH
BRUTALITY.
SO THE SOLUTION, EMASCULATION.
WE'RE NOT EVEN CALLING CRIME
CRIME ANYMORE.
SEE, THIS IS NOT CRIME.
IT'S REALLOCATIONS OF GOODS.
>> LOOK AT THIS. OH -- INSANE,
YO.
>> THIS IS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ULTA RIGHT NOW.
>> GREG: HMM, HE HAS A FUTURE OF
A CRIME REPORTER.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS, IF YOU
PLAY THAT VIDEO IN REVERSE, IT
LOOKS LIKE THESE GUYS WORK THERE
AND THEY'RE STOCKING THE
SHELVES.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
INSANE.
INSANE, YO.
THIS IS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ULTA RIGHT NOW.
>> GREG: PROBLEM SOLVED. HEY, IF
WE ONLY HAD THE POLICE THERE TO
GREET THEM AND HELP THEM LOAD
THE STUFF INTO THE STOLEN TRUCK.
YO, SARGE, MIND GRABBING THE END
OF THE FLAT SCREEN.
WE EXCUSE THE CRIMINALS WHO ARE
THE REAL THREATS, THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARD WHO REPRESENTS
90,000 SCHOOL OFFICIALS BEGGED
JOE BIDEN ON WEDNESDAY UPSET
OVER UPOVER MASK MANDATES FORCED
UPON THEIR KIDS SAYING PARENTS
SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE DOMESTIC
TERRORISMS BY EXTREMIST
ORGANIZATIONS.
YEAH, THE MOM LOOKING OUT FOR
HER KIDS IS THE SAME AS A
ONE-EYED MONSTER WITH A HOOK FOR
THE HAND SOME THEY IMPLORED JOE
BIDEN TO DEPLOY THE FBI.
THEY'LL PROBABLY LISTEN.
THE TEACHER'S UNION REALIZING
THE WORST THING ABOUT COVID IS
PARENTS REALIZING HOW BAD THE
UNIONS ARE.
AND NOW THAT PARENTS ARE TAKING
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE FROM THESE
IDIOT, THEY'RE CONSIDERED A
THREAT.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH THESE
SANCTIMONIOUS SELF-RIGHTEOUS
A-HOLES ARE A THREAT.
REMEMBER THE SOLDIER WHO SPOKE
UP ABOUT THE AFGHANISTAN
DEBACLE?
HE'S IN THE BRIG.
AND HOW ABOUT THE MAN WHO SAVED
THE BABY IN KABUL.
HE WAS INVITED UP BY DONALD
TRUMP LAST WEEK.
>> I PULLED THE BABY OVER THE
WALL AND IT'S ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS I'VE DONE IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
>> GREG: NOT SO FAST, BUSTER.
HOPPING ON THAT STAGE MIGHT HAVE
BROKE POLICY.
THEY TREAT HIM LIKE HE'S JOHN
HINCKLEY.
LIKE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ATTEMPTING THE BIGGEST PURGE
SINCE TYRUS WENT ON THAT JUICE
CLEANSE. YOU SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE?
WE'RE CRIMINALIZING CITIZENS AND
DECRIMINALIZING CRIME.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
BUT MAYBE IT'S THE ONLY WAY
DEMOCRATS CAN LOWER CRIME
STATISTICS. THE NICEST HOST AT
FOX NEWS AND IF YOU DISAGREE,
SHE'LL STAB YOU.
DANA PERINO.
AND THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
YOUR SCREEN.
THAT'S JUST HOW HE LOOKS.
WRITER AND COMEDIAN, JOE DEVITO.
HE'S LIKE AN ARMADILLO, TOUGH
EXTERIOR, BUT CURLING UP IN THE
BALL. FINALLY, WHAT BAND IS YOUR
WAISTBAND.
IN THE NWA WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION.
>> WELCOME TO NASHVILLE.
YOUF NEVER BEEN DOWN SOUTH
BEFORE.
IT'S QUITE AN EXPERIENCE.
YOUF BEEN ARRESTED NUMEROUS
TIMES FOR HORRIFIC TIMES.
THIS IS AN AGREEMENT THE COBS
MAY BE GREETING MORED.
>> THEY'RE GRUFF AND DISMISSIVE?
I LIVED IN NEW YORK TEN YEARS.
I'VE BECOME GRUFF AND DISMISSIVE
OVER THAT TIME.
NO, NOT REALLY.
I'M NOT.
THIS MIGHT BE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO HAVE
HOMELESS PEOPLE SITTING OUTSIDE
OF THEIR SHOPS FOR YEARS ON END.
ONE GIRL HAS BEEN SITTING
OUTSIDE THE JUICE GENERATION
FOR, I DON'T KNOW, EIGHT YEARS.
AND SHE'S PREGNANT FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
>> GREG: WOW, SHE'S BEGGING FOR
TWO.
>> DANA.
IF YOU HAVE CUSTOMER SERVICE
NOW, MAYBE THE BUSINESS OWNERS
CAN BE HELPED ALONG.
>> YOU'RE SAYING IT COULD BE A
GOOD IDEA ON THAT.
I MIGHT BE WRONG.
>> I DIDN'T SEE IT LIKE THAT.
>> HOW DID YOU SEE IT?
>> I SAW IT THEY WERE IMPLYING
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WOULD
TALK TO THE COPS BUT WORRIED
THAT THEY RUDE.
I WOULD SNITCH ON MY MOB BOSS
BUT I HEARD THE COPS DON'T SAY
PLEASE AND THANK YOU.
>> GREG: AND ALSO, AGAIN, LIKE
THAT LIBERAL THING WHERE THEY
SNIFF AROUND THE EDGES OF A HUGE
PROBLEM AND SAY PROBLEM IS
SOLVED BY SOLVING SOMETHING THAT
DIDN'T NEED SOLVING.
I DON'T WANT A NONGRUFF COP,
CAT.
>> I THINK YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
GRUFF IF YOU FIGHT CRIME.
IT WOULD BE WEIRD AND PASSIVE
AGGRESSIVE IF YOU WEREN'T.
>> WAS IT IS CRIME FIGHTING DOG,
McGRUFF?
>> HE DIDN'T SMILE.
>> GREG: HE DIDN'T SMILE AT ALL.
WHY WOULD YOU WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING BE DEAD IN 14
YEARS.
PROBABLY NOT A GOOD JOKE.
>> THANK YOU, DEAD DOG TO ME.
THANK YOU.
>> GREG: IT REMINDS ME OF YOUR
BEARD.
>> I WISH YOU COULD SHOW THE
CLIP OF DIBLASIO SO IT WILL GO
INTO HIS MOUTH.
THE IDEA THAT THE POLICE ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO CUSTOMER SERVICE.
HOW EXACTLY DOES THAT WORK WITH
YOUR ASSAULT CONVICTION?
YOU GET A FREE ICE CREAM SUNDAE?
AMAZING WHAT HE'S DONE TO NEW
YORK CITY.
IT'S LIKE IN THE MOVIES WHERE
YOU SEE THE CHARACTERS THROW THE
MATCH OVER HIS SHOULDER AND
EVERYTHING EXPLODES BEHIND HIM.
THAT'S BILL DIBLASIO EVERY DAY
WHEN HE LEAVES THE HOUSE
DESTROYING NEW YORK CITY IN SOME
NEW AND EXCITING WAY.
>> GREG: LIKE ME WHEN I LEAVE A
RESTROOM.
>> USE A MASK.
>> GREG: I RISK A LITTLE WHEN I
THROW THE MASK.
SHOULD HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
LOVE THE HAT.
>> FUNNY JOKE, GREG.
>> GREG: YOU GOT THE BOOTS AND
THE HAT?
>> EXCUSE ME WHILE I WHIP THIS
OUT.
ALWAYS WANTED TO SAY THAT. KIND
OF MAD ABOUT THIS.
IN MY YOUTH, PLEASE, GET ON THE
GROUND -- I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
TO A MANAGER.
THE COP IS LIKE, SORRY, SIR, BE
RIGHT BACK.
MORE TIME TO GET AWAY.
WE'VE JUST LOST OUR MIND.
CUSTOMER SERVICE -- PROTECTING
YOU FROM CRIMINALS IS CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
KICKING IN THE DOOR AND SAVING
YOU IS CUSTOMER SERVICE.
IF ANYONE NEEDS CUSTOMER
SERVICE, IT'S OUR MEN AND WOMEN
IN BLUE THAT NEED CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY TO
THE FAMILY OF SNAKES THAT GAVE
ALL OF THIS TO US, THANK YOU.
>> GREG: SNAKE SKIN?
>> IT WAS.
IT'S MY SKIN NOW.
>> GREG: ONE LAST ONE.
WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT HOW THE
TEACHER'S GROUP ARE CALLING
PARENTS POTENTIAL TERRORISTS.
WE ARE NOW -- WE ENTERED THE
STAGE WHERE WE'RE WE NEWSING THE
POTENTIAL THREAT.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THIS?
EVERYONE CAN BE A POTENTIAL
THREAT.
I'M A POTENTIAL THREAT FOR
POINTING THIS OUT.
EVERY SINCE THEY DID THIS WHOLE
THERE'S AN INVISIBLE TERRORIST
DOMESTIC THREAT, EVERYBODY COULD
BE FINGERED, AND NOT IN A GOOD
WAY.
>> OH, GOD.
>> GOOD ONE TO END ON, GREG.
>> AS A PARENT, THIS IS A
DOUBLE-EDGED SWORD.
THEY CRY WHEN WE DON'T GET
INVOLVED.
WHEN WE GET INVOLVED, HOW DARE
YOU -- YOU'RE A TERRORIST IF YOU
CALL ME OUT.
YOU'RE A TERRORIST IF YOU DON'T
AGREE WITH ME.
YOU'RE A TERRORIST IF YOU HOLD
ME ACCOUNTABLE.
WELL, I WILL CHANGE THAT.
WHAT'S THE NEW HAT SARA IS
WEARING THESE DAYS.
>> YOU WANT TO USE THE PATRIOT
ACT TO GO AFTER UNITED STATES